are you telling me there was something
wrong with the horse made a quick 300
yards from the finish she hit the
stretch and just quit turns out she
sucked up there you know a couple
gallons of air get trapped up in that
she cramps up but she can't run very
uncommon the working men of God's pocket
are simple men they work marry and have
children and until recently they died
like everyone else forty-two-year-old
construction worker was killed yesterday
when he slipped and fell to his death
Leon Hubbard didn't slip on nothing
something happened to Leon over that job
something nobody's told us yet I'll see
what I can find out Jeannie's got some
idea that something else happened on
that early on those hoping you can ask
around for make me you want me to talk
this out I just want to make Jeannie
feel better
can help you i Richard Shelburn of day
daily times I'm so sorry for your loss
go Mick the body messed up it's just the
back of his head
what I did has nothing to do with you
well you got to worry about is making
sure that everything is all right and
then you get your money mr. Shelburn I
need to know what happened to my boy
place
goodbye his body in the street Mickey
Leon was in the truck with the meat he
was separated from the meat I knew that
would upset you I've been writing the
story of this city 20 years I love this
city
massive superstar at all day in a
terrible
tell you about the often you get it up
you're getting blood all over your pants
you